Hi out there in internet land.
My name is Bob Nystrom.
I'm a Googler working
on the Dart Project.
Specifically, I spend most of my
time hacking on Pub, which
is our package manager.
But when I'm not doing that, I
spend a lot of time talking
about Dart online, in like
mailing lists, and Reddit, and
stuff like that.
So when we let Dart into the
wild last October, I mentally
prepared myself for wave
a of invective.
I figured there are few things
people love more than
complaining about new
programming languages.
I mean, there's few things I
love more than complaining
about new programming
languages.
But I was just prepared for
people saying Dart is bad
technically.
What made me a little sad
thought, was people saying
Dart was bad in the
moral sense.
Not just that it was a bad
language, but that it was bad
for the world, or at least the
web, for it to exist--
like it was evil.
In case you missed out, here's
my understanding of what
people were saying.
So back in the early days, of
the web, during the browser
wars of the '90s, Microsoft
created this language call
VBScript and put it in
Internet Explorer.
If you didn't want to write
your client-side code in
JavaScript, you could write
it in VBScript instead.
The rub, though, was
that VBScript was
only in Internet Explorer.
And that basically broke
the web in half.
So instead of a single
standards-based, open web that
all users can participate in
equally, you had this part of
the web using VBScript that
only worked in IE, and the
rest of the web that worked
in any browser.
And that's bad for users
because it stifles
competition.
If any given website only works
on a single browser,
then browsers can't compete
for that user's attention.
They're already locked in.
So then Google comes along
with our client-side web
language, Dart, and we talk
about having this nice native
virtual machine for it that we
want to put into Chrome.
And this starts to sound
like a familiar story.
So people got kind of nervous,
and angry, and started saying
not very nice things about us.
And that kind of made me
wonder, was I evil?
I mean, I don't feel evil, but
I'm guessing that most
villains don't, right?
Like maybe I'm on the
dark side and I just
don't realize it.
So I started doing some
soul searching.
This is me and my dog.
You can see I'm literally
soul searching here.
The dog is too, I guess.
Could this be the image of some
kind of evil villain?
Well, I found a couple
of problems.
First, try as I might, I'm
actually completely incapable
of growing a goatee or any
suitably sinister facial hair.
I can't even grow a mustache
that I could
twirl the ends of.
Also, every super villain seems
to have some sort of
animal familiar to protect
their evil lair.
And I have one, but she's not
like a vicious, mutant
half-shark, half-bear.
She's a half-Yorkie,
half-Pomeranian.
She's not going to protect
my evil lair.
But the most obvious reason I'm
not an evil overlord, is
that I'm not an over anything.
I have a boss.
And then the realization
hit me.
What if my boss or his
boss is the Overlord?
And what would that
say about me?
I would be a minion.
And do minions know that
they're minions?
Now, I don't want to be a
cog in some giant, evil
enterprise, so I spent a lot of
time thinking about Dart.
Of course, technology itself
has no morality.
A split atom isn't good or evil,
it's just a question of
whether you use it
in this or this.
So the question I asked
myself was, can Dart
be a force for good?
Can it be something that
helps the world?
I realize it looks like
I'm joking here, but
I really did this.
I care a lot about the integrity
of my work, and I
spend a lot of my free time
hacking on open source stuff.
And I do that, in large part,
because I love the feeling
that I'm making the world
a better place.
So that's kind of what
this talk is about.
After my soul searching, this
is the stuff that I found in
Dart that makes me think
that it isn't evil.
This is my story about how I
think Dart could help make the
open web better, and why
regular, non-evil web
developers might want to
consider using it.
But before I talk about Dart,
let's talk about the web.
For a long time, web developers
got a free pass
when it came to interactivity.
The web was designed for this,
physics papers and pages that
link to physics papers.
And that's pretty much it.
So when web developers
managed to get
stuff like this working--
this is Hotmail, circa 1997--
users were already impressed.
I mean, sure, you had to refresh
the whole page every
time you wanted to delete
a single email.
But you could check your email
from anywhere, right?
Well, unfortunately, bad news.
Mobile devices are here.
So web apps used to be awesome
simply because you could get
to your data wherever
you were.
And users were willing to give
up all sorts of user
experience niceties
to get that.
But omnipresence is no longer
a web exclusive.
Mobile apps are everywhere,
too.
And they connect to the cloud.
So anyone who has a smartphone
can check their email
anywhere, and they can do it
in some native app that has
smooth animation and
acceleration, multi-touch,
offline support, and cute little
sounds, and stuff.
And they never ever have
to refresh the page.
And that means users'
expectations have risen.
So great web apps these days
have to be great apps, and not
just great web apps.
We don't get to play the
web card anymore.
And that means no
page refreshes.
That means offline.
That means animation
and acceleration.
And all of that means more code
that's running on the
browser, a lot more.
Now, it wasn't that long ago
that 100 lines of JavaScript
was lot of code.
And a few years ago, the idea of
having the MVC side of your
app all running in the browser,
would have been
somewhere between crazy
and revolutionary.
But now, if you look, it seems
like there's a new JavaScript
MVC package coming out
every single day.
Now, I like JavaScript.
But what I've found is that the
bigger my apps get, the
less I feel like JavaScript
is a good fit.
It scales surprisingly well.
But what that means is that a
language that was designed for
about a dozen lines of code
works pretty well up to, say,
a few thousand.
But for comparison, EmberJS is
20,000 lines of code right
now, and that's just
the framework.
And at that scale, I struggle
with a language.
It doesn't mean there's
anything wrong with
JavaScript.
It just means that Brendan
Eich probably didn't have
anything like Google Maps in
mind when he was designing it.
And we're starting to write, not
just a lot of client-side
code now, but really diverse
client-side code.
The web has reached a level of
maturity where no one language
can meet everyone's needs.
And we been that on the server
side forever, but now the
browser is like that to.
The question is, how do you
bring new languages to the
browser in a way that doesn't
break the web?
How do you make a new language
without being evil?
And the answer is the same
answer that CoffeeScript, and
ClosureScript, and
others have.
You compile the JavaScript.
So there's a couple different
ways to run Dart code.
We have a native virtual machine
that executes Dart
code directly, sort of like
you would Python or Ruby.
And you can use that for
server-side coding.
And we hope to eventually put
it in Chrome and any other
browser that wants it.
We've also got something we
call Dartium, which is a
custom-built of Chromium, the
open-source version of Chrome,
with that native Dart
VM embedded in it.
And it's really handy during
development, because it means
you can iterate on your Dart
code without a compile step.
You just refresh the page like
you would with JavaScript.
And it means you can use the
Chrome Debugger, and debug,
and step through the original
Dart code and not unreadable,
generated code.
But completely separate from
those, but just as important,
we have something called
Dart to JS.
This is an offline compiler that
takes in an entire Dart
program and compiles the whole
thing to JavaScript.
So with Dart to JS, you write
all your code in Dart, and
then compile it to JavaScript.
And then you just deploy
that like you
would a normal JS app.
As long as your user's browser
can run relatively modern
JavaScript, they can
run your app.
They don't care or even know
that it was originally
developed in Dart.
What this means is that, yeah,
Dart works in Chrome, but
right now, today, it also works
equally well in Firefox,
Safari, and Internet Explorer.
You could run Dart on your iPad
or your Android phone.
Opera will be up here at some
point, but we've got
some bugs to fix.
So the goal here is that any
browser that supports modern,
standards compliant JavaScript
will support Dart too.
There's one last technical bit
that I should mention before I
start talking about the
language itself.
The Dart Project is fully
open-sourced.
It's ESD licensed, if you care
about particular licenses.
We work live in the
public repository.
Our bug trackers are public, our
mailing lists are public,
pretty much everything.
If you watch how we work it,
we're kind of closer to being
outside of Google than
inside of it.
Dart was designed by the same
people who created V8, which
is the JavaScript engine
in Chrome.
And the fact that V8 is open
source is what led Ryan Dahl
to build Node.js using it.
So open source is pretty
deeply ingrained
in the team's culture.
OK, now the fun stuff.
Now I can start talking
about the language.
I'm going to do a pretty quick
overview, since I don't really
know who's going to be watching
this or what the
audience is.
It's hard to go into details,
because stuff that would be
interesting to some people is
going to be really boring to
other people.
And the other reason I'll go
pretty quickly at first is
because Dart tries really hard
to be familiar to anyone
coming from a Java or JavaScript
background.
So here's a simple
Dart program.
It looks kind of like C and
JavaScript had a baby.
Dart inherits the same
expressions and statements
that you know from C, C++
Java, C#, or JavaScript.
You have your familiar
arithmetic operators.
You've got if then else, while
loops, for loops, all that
kind of basic stuff that
you take for granted.
declarations like main () look
like they do in C. And main ()
is the entry point
of your app.
But local variables are declared
using var, kind of
JavaScript.
And also, we've got nice
list literals.
We have map literals too, which
means that JSON is also
valid Dart syntax.
There's a couple of other
niceties going on here too.
We have a nice for in loop that
will let you walk over
any iterable collection.
Here you can see we have
string interpolation.
The little dollar sign curly
block encloses an expression.
And Dart will evaluate that
and insert the result in a
string for you.
If you like a more functional
style, this
example could be this.
Dart, of course, has closures
and nested functions like most
newer languages do.
Also, our built-in collection
classes have most of the
functional methods you would
expect like for each, and map,
and filter.
The little arrow here is our
syntax for lambdas, which is
just an anonymous function whose
body just returns the
result of a single expression.
In fact, you can use that arrow
syntax even for named
functions like main (), if
its body is just a single
expression.
So if you really want to go
down the functional rabbit
hole, this example could
look like this.
So, basically, Dart is like
your kind of vanilla curly
brace and semicolon imperative
language.
And then we poured a functional
chocolate sauce on top.
For people like me that care
about this kind of stuff, Dart
has solid lexical scoping.
Variables are blocked scoped,
not function scoped.
There's no weird hoisting
shenanigans.
Also, closures and loops
do the right thing.
If you close over a loop
variable, you'll get a fresh
one each iteration.
But that's kind of microscale
stuff though.
So let's go a bit bigger and
let's talk about classes.
So when programs get big, one
way we knock them down to size
is by breaking them down
into data types.
You encapsulate your code
in kinds of things.
And doing this was a design
pattern in languages like C.
And then became part of the
language in Simula, Smalltalk,
and then Java, Self, JavaScript,
you name it.
So most of these languages
defined kinds of
objects using classes.
JavaScript is a bit unusual, in
that inherited a different
model prototypes from a
language called Self.
Now, prototypes are very cool.
And they're very flexible, but
they're flexible in the way
that assembly language
is flexible.
They let you do anything, but
they kind of force you to do
everything yourself.
So, for example, let's say you
want to define a kind of
monster object in JavaScript.
Here's kind of the vanilla
way of doing it.
If you aren't fairly experienced
in JavaScript,
this is probably pretty opaque,
so I'll annotate it.
And this code has a couple
of problems with it.
First, it's really verbose
and repetitive.
We're mentioning monster
six times.
Game object shows
up three times.
That's the thing that we're
inheriting from.
Then there's all this prototype
machinery directly exposed.
So the intent to this code
is to define a kind of
entity in our game.
But what the code actually does
is just muck around with
JavaScript's dispatch
mechanics.
Now, there is a pattern here,
and if you know the pattern,
you can kind of squint through
it and see what's going on.
But if you don't, this is just
like semantic mystery meat.
The last issue, and possibly the
biggest, is that this is
all imperative code.
We aren't declaring
a type here.
We're molding it out
of unformed clay
one mutation a time.
And doing that's ugly, but
worse, it's opaque to tools.
So here's how you define
the same class in Dart.
Now, the obvious difference
is that this is a
lot shorter and simpler.
We now have a built-in syntax
to say I am creating a type.
So Dart lets you directly
express your intent in the
code, instead of requiring
you to know some pattern.
But once we have a class syntax
in the grammar, we can
hang some other nice
features off it.
So because the compiler knows
that we're inside a class
definition, it can let us use
super to call a super class
constructor method, so we don't
have to keep saying game
object over and over again.
We've got this nice little
syntactic sugar here to
directly initialize a field from
a constructor argument.
Over in the JavaScript code,
every field access was
preceded by this dot.
It's always this dot name
and not just name.
In the Dart code, that's gone.
Since we have solid lexical
scope, and we can
syntactically tell that we're
in a class and what fields
that class has, the compiler can
figure out that a variable
like name or attack refers to a
field, the same way you can
in Java or C++.
OK, I'll go over one more
really nasty JavaScript
pitfall that having a class
syntax lets us fix.
But it's a bit tricky
to explain, so I'll
need another example.
OK, here's some JavaScript
code.
We're creating a
monster object.
And it has this method,
makeYell function.
And that method returns
a function.
And when you call the function
that it returns, it prints the
monster's name.
The important bit here is that
this function is a closure.
It's accessing something
declared in an outer scope.
In particular, it accesses
this, which should be the
monster object that
the method is on.
So then down here, we call that
method to get the function.
And then finally, we
call the function.
So the question is, what
does this print?
So if you run this in node, it
prints this In a browser,
it'll do something different.
So if you got the right answer
here, congratulations.
That means you've gone through
the right of passage of being
burned by this, and you're a
real JavaScript programmer.
The problem here is that in
JavaScript, the special this
variable is dynamically bound,
not lexically bound.
When you call a method in
JavaScript, this is always
just like whatever object was
to the left of the dot when
you called it.
So if you do your mom dot is so
fat, then inside is so fat,
this will be bound
to your mom.
So when we call yell here,
there's no receiver at all.
It's not something dot yell.
So this defaults to the
global object instead.
And that's window
in the browser.
And if window were to happen to
have a name property, then
this would print whatever
that was.
The fix, in case you're curious,
is usually something
along these lines.
You get this and you capture it
in a variable that or self.
And then your closure refers
to that variable instead.
Since variables are lexically
scoped, this retains the right
object, the monster.
Now ultimately, this boils
down to the fact that
JavaScript doesn't distinguish
between functions and methods.
But if we translate this to
Dart though, we don't have
that problem.
Since we have a dedicated syntax
for classes, we also
have the distinction between
methods, like this one, and
functions, like this one.
So this is dynamically bound in
methods, which is what you
need for overwriting to work,
but it's lexically bound for
functions, which is what
you want for closures.
So that means that, in Dart,
this program does the right
thing and prints the
monster's name.
So having a class syntax lets us
do some kind of nice stuff.
But this is all kind of
small potatoes, right?
The big potato with this is
that now our tools can be
aware of the data types
in our program.
So with a declarative syntax,
you can see what types of
program defines, just
by parsing.
You don't have to execute
any code.
And this is something that
we take for granted in
statically-typed languages like
Java, but this is like
rocket science in a language
like JavaScript.
So I will ask you to remember
the bit about class syntax
being tool-friendly, because
I'm going to
get back to it later.
Now, I understand that classes
are a turn-off for a lot of
JavaScripters, because
Java left a bad
taste in their mouth.
In Java, everything has
to be in a class.
And you get this kind of kingdom
of nouns phenomenon,
where even a simple function
or variable has to be
ensconced in some boilerplate
class definition.
So Dart doesn't roll that way.
Up until now, the examples
I've showed you were just
simple top-level functions.
And you could define entire
programs just using those.
The way I look at it is, Dart
has classes, but it doesn't
have mandatory enrollment.
OK.
I want to talk about just a
few more corners of the
language that I think are united
by a common theme.
So I talk about Dart being
designed for bigger programs.
But apps don't start
big, right?
They start small and
then they grow.
And Dart has a few features that
I think are really cool,
because they help there, because
they keep you from
needing to do what I call
future-proofing.
So let me explain here.
Here's some Java code.
So, we have these get name
and get attacks methods.
And all they do is
return the field.
So why not just get rid of those
and make those fields
public instead?
Well, the answer, of course,
is that sure, they just
return field now.
But who knows, maybe a year down
the road we'll need to do
some calculation to determine a
monster's name or its attacks.
And when that happens, we'd have
to get every place in our
program where we're accessing
those fields, and replace it
with a call to our new method.
And if this changes in a library
that's been released
into the wild, that's a
breaking API change.
The reason it's a breaking
change is that accessing a
field and calling a getter
method in Java
have different syntax.
You can't transparently go
from a field to a method
without having to touch every
single call site.
And since you might need to do
that at some point, everyone
in Java just preemptively wraps
every single field in a
getter, just in case.
And that's what I mean
by future-proofing.
It's code that you write today,
just in case you end up
needing the flexibility
in the future.
And to me, that sucks, right?
You're basically burning time
writing code that has no value
for you today.
One of the things I like about
Dart is that you rarely have
to do that.
In Dart, that example
can just be this.
Name and attacks are
just fields.
So let's say we decide to not
to store the name and
calculate it instead.
In Dart, you could just change
that to a getter method.
And the important bit is that
the syntax for calling that
getter is 100% identical
to accessing a field.
So in this example, name
just has a getter.
So it's an immutable property.
You can read it, but you
can't modify it.
To make it mutable, you can also
define setter methods.
So here we've got a
setter method too.
So now you can assign to the
name property, and it invokes
that method with the
assigned value.
And again, the syntax between
setting a field and calling a
user-defined setter method is
identical at the call site.
OK, there's one other bit
of future-proofing
in this Java example.
So we're taking a list for
attacks instead of a built-in
Java array.
Why?
There's actually a couple
of subtle reasons.
But one of the big ones is that,
again, it's because the
syntax for using them
is different.
So if you go from one to the
other, it breaks all the code
that's using it.
And again, Dart has
you covered here.
Dart lets you define your own
subscript operators, the
square bracket thing.
So you can go from a built-in
list to some user-defined
collection and support the
exact same API that
the native list uses.
OK.
I won't go into the details
here, but this is a table of a
bunch of language features.
So you start off just using the
stuff on the left, which
all have built-in behavior.
And then later, if you find
you need to insert some
abstraction in there, the
features on the right let you
seamlessly roll that stuff in,
using your user-defined
behavior without breaking
any existing code.
So the idea is that when you
start writing your app, you
just write simple code that
does what you need today.
And then when it grows, the
language should be ready to
grow with you.
Now I'm here blathering about
language features.
But one of the things that
people keep asking me is, why
are you making a language
at all when the
platform is the problem?
And I think a lot of us
agree that the whole
web stack needs work.
And one of the things that's
cool about being at Google, is
that Google has people working
on pretty much every
corner of the web.
We have people doing HTML,
JavaScript, CSS, the DOM, new
HTML5 APIs.
But, in particular, let's
talk about the DOM.
So here's my understanding of
the genesis of the DOM API.
You've got a bunch of people,
the browser vendors, who
actively dislike each other,
and you've jammed them in a
room together.
And you told them they couldn't
leave until they all
agree on a single API.
And then you say, see how much
XML you can involve, the more
the better.
Oh, and also, don't
forget to make it
programming-language agnostic.
So any really cool language
feature that you like a lot,
yeah, you can't use that.
You can only use lowest common
denominator stuff that every
possible language supports.
So given that, the DOM API
didn't come out too bad.
But that's still a pretty awful
set of preconditions to
start from.
So Dart is a web language, so
of course it has full access
to the DOM API.
Dart isn't like Java applets or
Flash or something where it
just runs in a special little
rectangle in your page.
It's fully integrated
with the browser.
But since we are making a new
language, and we have this
Dart to JavaScript compiler for
it, we have a fantastic
opportunity.
We can also clean up the DOM.
So we've got a compiler that's
taking Dart code and spitting
out JavaScript.
And we can use that same
machinery to take calls to a
new, better DOM API, and then
turn them into calls to the
old school JavaScript DOM.
And that means we can ditch two
decades of old patterns
and historical cruft.
And we can stop pretending that
HTML was a flavor of XML.
And we can make an API that only
tries to be great for one
language and that fully uses all
of the features that are
particular to that language.
So that's what we're doing.
We've still got lots of work
to do, but I can show you a
couple of examples.
So let's talk about querying.
You've got your happy little
tree of nodes in your
document, and you want
to find some.
Here's how you can
do it in the DOM.
This is like an all you
can eat buffet, right?
So several years ago, John Resig
went to the mountaintop
and received this divine
revelation--
that thou shalt query for
elements using CSS selectors.
So we took that gospel
to heart.
And this is what we have
in our DOM API.
If you want one element,
you call query.
And if you want them all,
you call query all.
These are both simple
top-level functions.
You just call them.
There's no document
dot or anything.
So query all returns a
collection of elements.
What kind of collection?
The original DOM API had to
be language agnostic.
And that meant that it
couldn't rely on any
collection types that
were built into
a particular language.
So instead, it had to define
its own weird DOM-specific
slightly incompatible ones.
So when you get a list of
elements from the DOM in
JavaScript, it isn't a normal
JavaScript array, and it might
not have all the methods
that you expect.
But Dart's API is for Dart, so
we don't have that problem.
When you get a collection
from the DOM, you get a
full-featured collection that
supports everything that a
built-in list supports,
because it is a list.
So let's say you want to get
all of the non-empty button
labels on your page.
In Dart, you can just do this.
Since lists support map
and filter, the DOM
collections do too.
For arcane reasons, the
JavaScript DOM API hates
constructors.
So let's say you want
to make a button.
Here's how you would do it.
And that's kind of nasty.
Of course, in practice, you just
use jQuery or inner HTML
or something.
But to me, that's kind of just
routing around the problem.
In Dart, you can do this.
So when you're trying to learn
a new API, and you have some
type that you know you want an
instance of, the natural thing
to do is to try to
construct it.
So, with Dart, we just
make that work.
Also, notice that there's no
special append child or insert
adjacent HTML method
here to add the
button to the document.
Instead, we're calling add,
which is just the regular
method on lists.
So if you know how to add items
to a list, you already
know how to add elements
to the DOM.
Now, I won't claim that this
is some kind of like magic
pixie dust that's going
to somehow make all
of your apps awesome.
But I do think that small
improvements like these cut
down the time you spend chasing
down stupid little
bugs and typos.
And for me, when I'm less
frustrated, I am more creative.
OK.
If you've heard anything about
Dart, you're probably
wondering when I'm going
to talk about types.
So let's do that now.
So people who like
statically-typed or
dynamically-typed languages
historically have kind of a
rocky relationship
with each other.
People who like dynamic
languages seem to look at
static languages like Java as
being kind of boring and
plain, sort of just no fun,
vanilla languages.
And then, meanwhile, people into
static languages think
dynamically languages are too
unsafe and unreliable to use
for real production code.
And that the people who use
them are a little crazy or
maybe a little bananas.
So I don't know about you, but
when I look at those, what I
find myself wanting is this.
I should apologize for how
bad that metaphor is.
It's pretty terrible.
So anyway, our goal with Dart
is to try to get some of
what's great about dynamic and
static languages, and kind of
blend them together.
Now in their heart of hearts,
the guys who designed Dart are
much closer to the
dynamic side.
So Dart is mostly a
dynamic language.
They started with a purely
dynamic language, kind of in
the Smalltalk vein.
But then what they did is they
mixed in just a little bit of
static typing to try to get some
of the benefits of that.
But they wanted to do that
without giving up the
flexibility and the
open-endedness
of a dynamic language.
So, for example, here's
a chunk of Dart code.
The most important thing
about types in Dart in
that they're optional.
In Dart, you never have to write
a type annotation if you
don't want to.
That's why I've been able to
show a bunch of code samples
without a hint of
static typing.
So this Dart code here is
perfectly valid, because under
the hood, the language is
dynamically-typed, and it
doesn't need any static
types to run.
But, if you don't roll that way,
you can slather types all
over your code.
And that's fine too.
Maybe it's C++ nostalgia, or you
get paid by the volume of
code or something.
In practice, people seem to do
a mix, kind of like this.
They write types at the API
boundary, but they don't
usually worry about them
for things like local
variables or lambdas.
So if you do that, if you
sprinkle a few types in your
code, then Dart gives you
some benefits in return.
So this is jQuery's
contains method.
And you notice that most of
the documentation is just
describing the types that
those parameters allow.
It would be hard to use
this method without
those comments, right?
Would you have known that
you couldn't pass a
jQuery object to it?
So doing this in documentation
works.
But programmers don't have
the best reputation for
maintaining docs.
So having types gives you a
really light way of writing
this kind of documentation.
And we found that just by making
it easier, that people
are a good bit more likely
to actually do it.
OK.
So I'm going to switch over to
the Dart Editor now, which is
a free, open-source, kind
of lightweight IDE
we're working on.
OK.
I will do the world's quickest
demo of what types let us do
in the editor.
So we'll start really simple.
So here, we have a function
that's supposed to draw some
stuff on to a DOM element.
And aside from the fact that it
doesn't do anything, this
is valid Dart code.
But let's say we want to
make it clear what kind
of elements we allow.
We're going to be drawing using
the Canvas API, so we'll
annotate it to only accept
Canvas elements.
And to do that, we
just do this.
So now anyone looking at this
code can see what kinds of
elements are kosher here.
So already, this is useful for
people reading the code.
But since type annotations are
part of the language grammar,
the tool can see them too.
So when I was talking about
classes earlier, I said having
a declared a syntax for classes
helps with tools.
The missing piece was having
type annotations that mention
those tools, those classes.
So now that we've got
both, I can show you
what I'm talking about.
So let's go ahead and implement
this function here.
[TYPING]
OK.
So maybe I'm easily impressed,
but to me, that's pretty
awesome, right?
We have full autocomplete going
on for the DOM API.
And that's really helpful when
you're trying to learn your
way around a new library,
especially a big
one like the DOM.
And it's especially helpful with
stuff like Canvas here,
where you have methods that take
a lot of arguments, and
it's easy to forget what
the order is, or
which ones are optional.
The reason the editor can do
this is because it knows what
types are associated with
variables, and it knows what
methods those types support.
And, of course, if it knows what
those types are, it also
knows where they are.
So we can do this, too.
So we've got go to definition
working.
Now, of course, once you've got
types and your tool can
understand them like this, the
next thing you want it to do
is tell you when you're
using them wrong.
So we can do that too.
Let's go ahead and get
something wrong.
So we'll try setting
the line width.
[TYPING]
Now I'm going to guess that it
takes a string so that I can
specify CSS units.
Now when I try that, as soon
as I do, I get a warning
immediately in the editor
telling me I'm doing the wrong
thing, instead of having to
spend who knows how much time
debugging the stuff at runtime
in my browser.
Now, I feel a little silly
making a big deal out of this,
because anyone coming from
Visual Studio or Eclipse is
like, yeah, this is
kind of old news.
But this kind of error checking
is kind of a rarity
in client-side web
programming.
But what I think is particularly
cool here is that
we got this error checking
without having to put a
lot of effort in.
You'll notice that this entire
program has exactly one single
type annotation, just that one
little Canvas element up here.
And that's enough for the editor
to figure out what I'm
trying to do and let me know
when I've got it wrong.
I hate tracking down stupid
bugs, so this is kind of like
sunshine and rainbows for me.
OK.
So for us, those are pretty much
the big things that we
want to get out of types.
We want better API
documentation.
We want code navigation, so you
can learn your way around
a code base.
We want autocomplete, so that
you can discover what methods
type support as you use them,
and learn an API interactively
in your editor.
We want some basic error
checking, so you can catch
typos and type errors.
And that's really the major
stuff, like maybe some
refactoring support.
Oh, and there's one more thing
that types let us do.
This is something that
I think is--
I personally think is really,
really cool and could possibly
be a big deal for the web.
So, I'm pretty new to
web programming.
And as I was learning my way
around, I looked at a bunch of
sites for various JavaScript
libraries.
And I started noticing something
that seemed a
little odd to me.
So this is jQuery's website,
and the little arrow is
pointing to-- it's telling me
how big the library is.
Why do I care about this?
I don't remember any C++
libraries being like, hey,
we're only 5K of code
or whatever.
This is Mootools.
It's pointing to compact, so
here, I guess, being small is
important enough to be
part of its branding.
This is Raphael.
Here, it mentions small
in the text.
And it highlights
the file size.
And it goes out of its way to
tell you how big it is after
you gzip it.
This is Bootstrap.
Bootstrap doesn't
seem to care.
Oh, unless you look
under the fold.
So here, that cares too.
And finally, the ultimate
example of this is Zepto.
So with Zepto even the name
is about how small it is.
The whole goal of Zepto's
existence is to be small.
Their pitch is hey, you know all
that cool stuff in jQuery?
We took most of that out.
And that's kind of
like, that's it.
Now, just to be clear, the
designers of these libraries
are doing exactly the
right thing for the
world they live in.
They're not crazy.
If you look, Zepto calls out
the problem right here.
Every line of JavaScript in a
library that you use has to
get pushed down the wire
to the user's browser.
And unless you really, really
clever, every line you send
down adds a tiny bit of
delay before users can
start using your app.
So the bigger the libraries
you use, this slower
your app starts up.
So minimizing library
size is the only
way to get fast startup.
My background, strangely
enough, is video games.
So this seems totally
crazy to me.
I certainly cared about
code size, because I
was coming from C++.
So I had template expansion,
and limited game RAM, and I
had this pathological aversion
to instruction cache misses.
But I never thought well, can't
use this library, it's
got functions that
I don't call.
Because eliminating dead code
is the linker's job.
Where's my linker
for JavaScript?
Well, part of the problem is
that it's really, really hard.
So here's some JavaScripts to
create a monster object with
an attack method.
Now, the question is, is that
method ever called in our
program, or can we
strip it out?
Well, obviously, if we see
something like this, then
yeah, it's probably in use.
But you can also do
this, or this.
So this calls the attack method,
but only on Tuesdays
and Thursdays and, I think,
only in certain locales.
So, in general, it's not
possible to statically tell
what code is reachable
in JavaScript.
Everything is mutable,
everything is imperative.
And everything can be reached
by name, using strings
constructed at runtime.
And that kind of flexibility
is super fun for
metaprogramming, but it's the
kiss of death when you want to
do stuff that relies
on static analysis.
But dead code elimination
isn't impossible.
Lispers and Smalltalkers have
been doing this forever,
because they've apparently been
doing everything forever.
So Lispers call dead code
elimination tree shaking.
They think of their
code as a tree.
And the root of the
tree is main().
And then the branches are
everything that main () calls,
and then everything that those
things call, and so on, all
the way out to the leaves.
And code in your program
that doesn't get called
is just dead wood.
Now, imagine grabbing the trunk
and shaking it hard.
All of the loose, dead branches
that aren't actually
connected fall off, and what
you're left with is just the
live tree, just the stuff that
you can reach from the root.
So in Dart, doing this
is pretty easy.
We have a declarative
syntax for classes.
So we know what methods
every type supports.
We have type annotations.
So it's pretty easy to tell
what types of objects are
stored in variables.
And then we also have a
declarative syntax for
importing modules.
And that's enough to get a
decent picture of which code
is in use and which isn't.
So we have this Dart to
JavaScript compiler, but it
doesn't just turn your Dart
code into JavaScript.
It reads in your entire program,
your app, and every
single library it uses.
And then it grabs your main
() function, and shakes
the hell out of it.
And it only generates code for
the stuff that's left, the
code that's called.
Now, our hope is that this means
that code reuse will be
much easier in Dart.
You can just make libraries
that do useful stuff.
You shouldn't have to agonize
over, can I add this function
to my library, or will
that make it to big
and scare off users?
And when you use a library, the
compiler will shake out
the stuff you don't call.
The only code that gets pushed
down the wire is the
code that you need.
And you only pay for
what you use.
OK.
So you survived the fire
hose of slides.
I pushed a whole pile of stuff
onto your mental stacks, so
I'll pop the important
bits off.
First of all, the JavaScript
community has code reuse
problems, because download
sizes limit the size of
libraries you can use.
And if we're lucky, tree shaking
to eliminate dead code
automatically will help
solve that for Dart.
Taking a dynamic language and
then layering on just some
really simple, optional static
typing can give you
autocomplete, code navigation,
error checking, maybe
refactoring support, most of
the stuff you expect from a
fully static language, without a
lot of the restrictions of a
mandatory-type checker.
You can make the DOM a lot more
awesome if you just pick
one language, and that
language isn't XML.
Language features like getters
and setters and operator
overloading that let you take
built-in syntax and give it
your own user-defined behavior
are like super awesome,
because they save you from
having to write a bunch of
pointless future-proofing
boilerplate code when your app
is starting out.
And then they give you
flexibility when
it grows over time.
Having language support for
classes makes it a lot easier
for programmers to express their
intents declaratively,
gives you a bunch of nice,
little features and it makes
tooling way easier.
And finally, compilation to
JavaScript is awesome.
It lets us all have new
languages on the client
without breaking the open web.
And it lets Dart work on every
major modern browser, right
now, without any effort on the
users' or the browsers
vendors' part.
So if I'm very lucky, hopefully
I've piqued your
interest in Dart.
If you want to learn a little
bit more and try it out, I
strongly encourage you to
check out dartlang.org.
We've got examples, and
tutorials, and documentation,
all sorts of stuff like that.
You can download the SDK.
It works on Linux,
Mac, and Windows.
You can also download
the editor, which
includes the SDK.
And it also includes Dartium,
which is our custom browser
with the Dart VM installed.
If nothing else, I
think it's really
cool to try out Dartium.
And just write a little bit
of Dart code, because the
experience of having a new
language running natively in a
browser, it has an
interesting feel.
Even if you ultimately don't end
up liking Dart, it's kind
of cool seeing what it's like
to have a language that just
runs directly in the browser,
and can talk to the DOM that
isn't JavaScript.
Anyway, so that's it.
Thanks for your time.